here we go. But I promise I'm not actually a depressing person. So climate change drives
many different exposures that are linked across the continuum of cancer care.
These include greater exposures to known carcinogens, influences on human behavior
that similarly increase risk of cancer acquisition, as well as disruptions in cancer
treatments and additional issues into survivorship. This diagram gives us an overview of how
emissions lead to climate change and then how they interact with various cancers.
So far, this has been best described for lung, skin, GI cancers, and the mechanisms for exposure
include direct changes to the air, like increases in particulate matter exposure that lead to
higher incidence of lung cancer, changes in clothing worn during the spring months leading
to increased UV exposure and higher rates of melanoma, decreased nutritional quality leading
to higher rates of GI cancers, et cetera.
But.
But while a lot of exposure studies focus on cancer acquisition, there are recent examples
relevant to oncology clinicians, such as this example showing how wildfire exposure for
individuals who just underwent a curative lung cancer surgery is associated with higher rates
of death, with the greatest risk associated with exposures in the first six months after surgery,
which is something potential. Oh, yeah, yeah, sorry. Sorry. So just this, this is one example
connection that's been drawn that's relevant to oncology.
Clinicians, which is essentially that patients who just went to underwent curative lung cancer
surgery and were exposed to wildfires within the first six months after the surgery had
higher risk of death. And you can kind of see the dose response here. But but the thing is that
outside of lung GI skin cancers, there's limited data. So we're wondering what might be clinically
intervenable issue in the heme malignancies. And despite me not being a myeloma clinician,
we settled on myeloma because there is environmental health literature,
that there's consistent associations between heat exposure and death that are mediated in the short
term by heat stroke and cardiovascular death and in the long term by renal dysfunction. And we all
know that in myeloma, there's a variety of mechanisms through which myeloma impacts renal
function and is also associated with increased mortality. So we really wanted to know if this
heat exposure in patients with myeloma increased the risk of death. And if so, to what extent was
that mediated by renal dysfunction? So we teamed up with some partners in the
American Cancer Society and NASA who have access to the National Cancer Database, and then granular
longitudinal heat exposure data across the US to assess that question. And we looked at all patients
diagnosed from 2004 to 2022. And we use generally accepted definitions of heat exposure, looking to
see initially if there was a proxy signal for death by assessing peri diagnostic heat exposure,
so heat exposure in the first week after diagnosis. And then when patients have uncontrolled disease,
an AKI, and then we looked at the kind of the cumulative heat exposure across their whole disease
course. So there were 335,000 patients in this analysis. And for the peri diagnostic kind of
first look, about 1% of those had any heat exposure in the first week, and then a smaller
number had heat exposure kind of in the heatwave definition of four more days. And as you can see,
on the right, there's kind of this hint of a signal, which is just what we were looking for.
Since this is just peri diagnostic exposure, we really surmise that this association was
likely driven by exposure to additional heat throughout the treatment courses for the patients
that had it in their first week. And you can see somewhat of a dose response here as you get to four,
five, six, seven days with the hazard ratios going up, albeit modestly.
But this is kind of the main slide, essentially. Our main interest was really this cumulative
exposure, which you can see here. And we used what is called a marginal structural model,
where you estimate the probability that each person actually had their observed
exposure at the time point that they had it, and then weights individuals so their exposure becomes
independent of confounders, meaning like, if two people were the same other than their heat
exposure history, how would their survival differ? This approach accounts for time-varying dynamic
exposures like heat, confounders that impact prior exposure like renal dysfunction, as well
as things that we generally adjust for age, sex, race, comorbidities, hospital type,
year of diagnosis, location, transplant in a time-varying way.
The nice thing about this approach is that it's causal inference. And so instead of providing just
an association between heat exposure and survival, it allows us to kind of causally infer the degree
to which heat actually causes death. And so you can see here there was a dose response relationship
where the more heat you're exposed to, the greater your likelihood of death. And I put
up where U.S. cities fall on this in terms of the fraction of days per year that they have
with our definition of heat exposure. And you can see that for places like Boston, where I
am, it may not be such a big issue, but places like Houston, Phoenix, this is getting into
territory where we think it really might matter. One thing that we did see was on the bottom left
that only about 22% of this increase in the hazard ratio was actually attributable to renal dysfunction,
which makes us think that there's probably other longer-term cardiovascular impacts that have been
coming out more recently as it relates to heat exposure in the general population. So we're
going back right now to do some more of those analyses. So what does this mean for us? Here are
some of the take-home messages for climate change studies in general that are relevant for people
with cancer. And I've bolded the two that I've mentioned today. A lot of the worst effects of
climate change are being borne out by those in the Global South and low-middle-income countries. But
I think we also need to recognize that those with chronic illnesses like cancer and myeloma need to
be considered as very vulnerable to this and something that we should really think about
during our current practice. Thanks.
Thank you.